i had a callus on my left hand
from doing the uh are you can street
fighter 2 motion so much because it
involves a joystick in a semi-circle to
the right i did it so many times
that i i developed a callous
i mean you can see it comparably the
left to the right all right look at that
man
that's your video game scars my video
game counts point of pride man point of
pride
i [ __ ] ruled
as ken ryu but i was uh disconcertingly
effective balrog so balrog is the boxer
not a good character okay so if you were
playing like canon ryu you could
generally you think you could just like
fireball him into submission but what he
did have is he had a power
where
he could actually uh spin through a
fireball and punch you
if you timed it perfectly um it's
difficult a time i was very good with
him but i still couldn't know but you
know when i could time it the beginning
of the round i would hold all three
punch buttons down and then whoever i'm
fighting nine times out of ten they're
gonna do a fireball so so they do the
fireball and i time through it
so then i punch them and then they're
just like what just happened i just did
like a customary opening
and i just got punched so then they jump
in the air to do like a jumping kick
which is like the next most uh like
basic effective thing this is how i went
and then i'm and i'm expecting it
so
so
so then you're the worst you're like the
guys i play online that just [ __ ] on me
and whatever game i play
uppercut that would punch him out of the
air so at this point then half the time
i'd be able to get a third shot in and
because i'd hit them three times in
succession they they'd be dazed for a
second it does a number on someone's
confidence so bad if you love that you
remember vividly this is your teenage
years or is this this college man i've
got to go to college and just play
street fighter 2 in the student center
[Music]
it was mostly asian dudes anyone who is
my age
[Music]
you